you know as i said we're trying a lot of
different things lately and one of the
things
that we tried uh not too long ago is we
started trying to
put a bit of a spotlight on people that
work here behind the scenes at the show
make it a little bit about them because
it kills time
and it's a nice thing to do uh but i
really did want to actually get more
involved in their lives and help out a
little bit
so recently i said to the staff if
anybody has
a problem something that's bothering
them something about their life here at
late night with conor o'brien that's
less than perfect i'm very accessible
please
come to me and uh tell me your problem
and i will do my best to fix it and i
meant it i really wanted to help out
not too long ago someone who works here
at the show very nice guy named aaron
blair
came to me and he said that he had
something that was troubling him
something behind the scenes here at the
show that wasn't quite working for him
and he wanted my help
i decided to help him and i brought a
camera crew
along and here's what happened
i'm here with aaron blair aaron your
role is you don't have to wave like that
sorry
just just be there be there
that's friendly listen you are a
researcher at the show uh correct
okay what uh what's the problem that you
would like me to fix well it's kind of
it's an issue in the men's bathroom
uh here on nine and it's kind of makes
me uncomfortable it's an awkward
situation this is the men's bathroom why
don't we go inside and you show me the
problem and i'll try to fix it sound
good to you i agree this is one of the
nicer bathrooms i've seen
what's your freaking problem blair and
my problem is
that it's the urinal here you pretend
like you're
going to the bathroom okay all right so
i'm here i'm at the area
okay everything's fine right zip cut
thunk you know what i'm saying that
zip cuff punk kind of what happens
when conan unleashes the beast all i'm
saying is i stand here
zip ka thunk and then waka chuckle
juggle what you're going to do
a lot of urine coming out anyway so i'm
standing here i'm doing my business
what's the problem
well my problem is let's say i was doing
my business in a stall
okay right and i come out i want to wash
my hands right
now the issue is that i have to look
down to wash my hands
and there's you know i'm saying there's
no there's no partitioning it's very
awkward what are you talking about well
it's like
i'm not looking why are you looking over
this way i don't want to look over that
way
but something deep inside you draws you
towards it you see a guy standing at the
urinal and you're like
i can't help it well it's woven you know
why are you this is a problem in other
bathrooms
no one problem is that when washing your
hands you feel that you're
you're what you just do no i flushed it
by accident
i didn't you're just bad with toilets
let's sum up yeah one is that when
you're washing your hands you feel that
your eye is drawn
too easily to someone else's business
the other problem you have is that when
you're doing your business you're afraid
someone might see
what's happening south of the border
with you yes i want to help you aaron
thank you
i want to make this okay for you so i'm
going to pitch
some possible solutions okay okay let's
try the first solution
okay aaron here's my solution uh two
interns
creating a wall right here you're free
to
uh use the bathroom and nobody
who's washing their hands you know if
they peek through here they're a little
cool
this isn't how i mean there's more
people in here now right but they're
blocking yeah it's like an audience now
he's staring right at my face yeah but
he's staring at your face oh well i
don't know that's not
staring at little aaron well it's just
saying trying to urinate staring to the
eyes of another man is difficult
i don't like i can't there's way too
many people here now and they're very
close
all right thanks guys we'll try
something else could you uh please go to
my bathroom
and resume your position there that's
how i do it
let's bring this in right now this is
gonna help a lot of people now
i had this made you just jam it in there
you walk in with this under your arm
you say time to urinate first take out
the old
divider and then get busy this is fine
but i look like some kind of freak
carrying this thing around
like he's obviously gonna go urinate
he's got his urination board no
no one knows this is a no one's gonna
see this and go oh that's one of those
urination boards
i mean i like this idea i just think
it's gonna pigeonhole me as a freak
in this office you were pigeonholed as a
freak when this process began
okay aaron i spent a lot of time and
i've spent a lot of money
i think i have the solution you ready
yes
okay how's that uh pretty good all right
why don't you uh
go ahead aaron and uh take care of
business okay
i can't go if you're in here with me
right it's kind of an idiot
let's almost get him out here aaron
[Music]
playart
okay owen i'm taking over control all
right folks we're gonna take a break
we'll be right back
with jim gaff again everybody